how will you reach the 315 billion years
target what's the question I was most
frequently asked when I visited 28
countries in 10 months the investment
plan road so studied in Romania and
finished in Slovenia I met stakeholders
students parliamentarians other
important questions we're also who
chooses the projects and how do i submit
the project I explained how the
investment plan works and listen to
people's ideas and concerns the feedback
from our discussions from students to
ministers was always that they learned a
lot and I learned then after each trip I
came back to my office and spoke to my
team about how we can improve even
further all the visits were tailor-made
for its top of the roadshow to maximize
interaction with citizens many of the
road shows included citizens dialogues
they created strong media coverage
in total we had 74 stakeholder meetings
91 high-level political meetings 31
project species 25 parliamentary meters
at least 96 press phones and we read
around four thousand two hundred
participants at citizens dialogue
excellent communication achieved prada
advocacy networking and engagement it
allowed for tailor-made local
communication to the widest possible
audience so people could to know the
backstage of the initiative the channel
aim was not to explain details of the
investment plan but also to talk about
the future of Europe and current for
this use in the we are investing in your
future